today's episode is brought to you also
by liquid death grateful for them
oh
i um
man
it's nice to have some relief from the
snow it burnt my skin i didn't know snow
could burn your skin up and it can even
though it's a
a cold feature it can burn you
um anyway
uh
today's guest
is a young man out of california
and he is uh he's just hilarious
you know he's very outgoing vivacious he
makes a lot of beautiful um material out
there on
instagram tiktok
um
he just he's the viral video you know
he's are you that guy that's when you
see you just
that's his new tour are you that guy
um
and he'll talk about it we'll talk about
it
um
you know he's a comedian he's a uh
he's just a
he's a damn just energy man you know and
he puts it out there in ways that people
uh like to laugh at and and with
and i'm one of those people today's
guest is my friend mr trevor wallace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah because i'm supposed to head back
to i was supposed to head back to l.a
tomorrow
or to tonight actually but my flight got
um canceled yes a lot going on out there
yeah i always thought nashville was like
72 minimum yeah oh yeah it gets brisk
man we just i actually just went
sledding this morning actually did you
yeah how was it i feel like doing
anything like i went bodyboarding like
couple weeks ago insane just great
bodyboarding and what is it body water
body okay waves you were out in the uh
what are you talking about in what bot
what uh ocean what ocean were you in
santa monica pacific atlantic which one
is that one i'm not going with you
that's pacific pacific yeah that's an
easy one yeah i know my rights from my
left and north south and east and west
but but oceans
that's an easy i don't know that one
oceans are i'm trying to think how much
i know ocean's 11. yeah
but could you name 11 ocean do you think
i think i could name 11 cities i have
oceans
huntington hermosa
is cheating bro santa monica venice
you're riding a lot of that same ocean
man yeah that's true
i met some people the other day from
bahrain was that's what i was like why
yeah i was like are you guys like
where'd you meet him huh where'd you
meet the airport oh yeah i was like are
you guys
and i don't even know what to ask i'm
like are you right what's offensive and
what's not or just like no not even
ethnic ethnical i was just gonna be like
are you guys like i didn't even know
what to say yeah yeah like are you lost
at the airport
do you believe in magic you know what
i'm saying i didn't know what to do i
feel like they would where is that by
the way that's what see that's where i
was
even where the thing was what was it
called again that's oh that was see all
of that was happening for me at one time
so i was like how many did you write on
a piece of paper yeah they're like we're
from bahrain and all right
it kind of sounds like byron it kind of
did you meet joe yeah joe byron bing
bong it sounds like uh
by humbug too what is that i know what
it is but i don't know what it is ba
humbug is like a famous saying from
humber christmas that's like when you
stub your toe and you're like bob humbug
or somebody like stole some [ __ ] for you
like humbug oh bob they got the
playstation
humbug was like a famous saying for
people that i think weren't uh were
angry like if yeah like if your
grandfather like if you asked him for a
dollar and he didn't want to buy a
dollar they'd do anything but cuss back
in the day yeah anything but cuss but
they would also like hit people and
you're like i feel like there's a better
alternative you could just cuss but they
would hit them with a can like are we
talking seniors you mean seniors yeah
are we yeah seniors i think we did yeah
you uh
i remember my girl i had a girlfriend's
uh grandmother one time just slapped me
right across the face and her
grandfather slapped me after huh after
yeah the alley-oop is like [ __ ] my
turn bad or bad or swing swing you know
different ah
yeah that is weird what did you do to
deserve that oh made love to their
granddaughter i think that's enough
that usually what it is
i think so if i'm especially and she was
she was very attractive and
if i'm the grandfather and i have an
attractive granddaughter
[Laughter]
or just any granddaughter yeah right
would you and somebody's making love to
or i think i'm not gonna be
i think it would be hard to be really
stoked about it
but yeah because if you're too excited
then it's weird then it's gets a little
pornhub categories grandpa gets excited
over prom day all right where's this
going i'll watch yeah grandpa is just by
the door with like a big like
listening thing or something you got a
red solo cup with a string in it yeah
would you be the guy meeting like a
daughter and then like at prom are you
shaking the guy's hand hard are you kind
of just like what's up man good to see
you
oh dude i think in the movies they're
always trying to be like intimidating
but like oh i was so i remember wasted
at one time at prom we i went to pick up
my date right i was too drunk there you
go uh you driving or no ah
probably floating a little bit i was
definitely
all different colors red white and blue
yeah i was like damn why am i a mushroom
yeah yeah do real well so you're picking
her up oh well i had to send my friend
in to pretend he was me because the dad
had never even met me
was he hotter like buffer oh that's a
good idea it was my friend lance yeah he
was definitely um
he was more he was honestly in hindsight
he was more attractive and here's the
crazy part they ended up looking up
yeah what did you do
i was like getting jerked off you went
into the house to meet the dad later
like you trying to play some madden real
quick i got two i was just too wasted
yeah yeah i feel like worse did you ever
you ever get too wasted before a day all
the time i remember one new year's i uh
uh we there was a there's a bottle of
absolute it's like a hundred proof and
it comes like a disco ball looking thing
and i remember i like brought it to the
party thinking i was like the dude i was
like yo i got this like bringing you
know coors light to a frat party we in
here yeah but i drank the whole thing
and i woke up just under their dining
room table and pissed myself oh really
yeah
so are you laying face down or face up
face down oh yeah but i was like under
under the table like mentally like in my
drunk mindset i was like that looks like
a blanket just a levitating blanket oh
yeah it was an interesting place to pass
out um yeah that's manly though the
saddest way to pee yourself is laying on
your back
just like casket just registered there's
something about like
you're like you would because here's
what happens like you're like in like in
er or something you're like waiting for
someone to put
you know a colostomy bag in you or
something
for me it's like if i wake up and i've
urinated myself
and i'm laying on my back it feels like
it's the weakest it's just like because
i was so vulnerable because i i didn't
envision myself actually having done it
somebody walks by and like oh this guy's
up pissing himself off just kissing
himself yeah i don't know it feels weak
face down is sad somebody face down and
pee
[ __ ] he peed himself but if you're on
your back and you pee yourself that's
like i remember i was in a frat shocking
i was in a frat but like if you passed
it with your shoes on people could just
[ __ ] with you right just whatever that
was the just tape a coat can to your
forehead yeah it was like if your shoes
wrong you were good and if they're
saucony's you're getting your ass beat
yeah exactly but it's like that was such
a weird and it was like i feel like a
lot of people listening would know that
that was like a general rule if your
shoes were on when you passed out you
were like fair game you could play
tic-tac-toe on the forehead with a
sharpie and like no repercussions yeah
draw a dick on their cheekbone we had a
dude who had who was like men uh he
wasn't he wasn't like he was like
paraplegic or whatever and they would
braid his legs when he got wasted
like a like a like a boy scout type of
knot no not like a boat knot or nothing
yeah that would [ __ ] that would kill
him but just kind of yeah
his grandfather would slap you if you
did that oh yeah that's what grandpa's
coming back in with the so after you got
slapped by grandpa did you would you
just take it or you [ __ ] be like i'll
[ __ ] pull the double a's out of your
life alert right now oh i remember
because i didn't know what their
traditions were i think they were greek
i could see that there's always kissing
you on like the cheeks so they might be
slapping you on the cheeks when you get
over near the mediterranean you you
don't know what's gonna happen you know
they they had a little bit of that joe
they had a little joey diaz somewhere in
him right you like hummus
i just got big on that [ __ ] really i
don't even know i put it on a carrot i
was like i didn't know you could do this
it feels like a oh
it kind of feels like ranch for [ __ ]
call me a [ __ ] [ __ ] that's i don't
know i like it dude i don't like celery
because the strings in it piss me off
it's like a guitar in there
but i feel like you're like doing
something you know i could never do it
just for a meal like like just a plant
diet a little much
a little much for me
i would never but um
yeah my flight i was getting my flight
got canceled that's what we're talking
about yeah luckily i flew in yesterday
but it is i mean they were asking if i
wanted to cancel shows i was like don't
[ __ ] i don't know don't look at me
yeah i guess who makes that decision
they put it on me did that yeah they're
like do you want to cancel we can move
this [ __ ] i was like i don't [ __ ] i
don't know what snow is to y'all i
didn't even know that we were in
tennessee like i knew we were in
tennessee but like did i know that we
were in tennessee right and that's every
place you kind of go it's like you don't
really you're never in a place long
enough to really like
you know yeah people are always like
sending you messages like hey man come
you know we're doing my cousin owns a
roofier factory dude we'd love to have
you stop by and you want to do all these
things it's sometimes it's just a lot to
be able to take on but oh it's too much
you never really know you're in a place
kind of well i also don't want to make a
call based on y'all's weather where i
say something and people are like you
cancel for that and i'm like i don't
[ __ ] know i remember when deleon one
time canceled for snow he got so much
[ __ ] online i mean people were yelling
at me probably and he got a lot of it
from me
cause he shouldn't but that's what i'm
saying it's like you cancel for snow bro
which is basically let's be honest gay
one
okay gay rain
okay let's be honest it's very powdery
out there today it's like i was i was
telling your boy they're pretty it's
nice to walk on you feel like you're
like is this the next step to heaven oh
i literally i woke up this morning i
watched miracle on 34th street or 38th
street shirt on or off
turn off bro there we go
chain on
uh chain on yeah chain on no shirt oh
how that movie should be intended to be
well on no shirt yeah that's definitely
that is a
that's definitely a gypsy wedding i feel
like that's like yeah it seems like yeah
you're the ring bearer actually yeah
i feel like is listening to christmas
music past christmas is that what's your
take on that like like in june
oh i
i i been listening to christmas music
for probably
i've listened more after christmas when
the stress is gone from the holidays
yeah and the views are down a little
lower yeah the views are lower so you
don't feel like you're bandwagoning but
like is michael buble still pulling in
plays in june probably i go old school
i'm like bing crosby you know like that
old like oh gee yeah i don't know what
he looks like but it's like yeah i go
bingo what if like when back in the day
they're like i'm gonna start doing
christmas music they're like yeah shut
up like okay that's that's what you want
to do christmas music but now
the numbers don't lie oh now i think for
certain people it's there but back in
the day it's like you oh you think you
can compete with jesus christ yeah it
was a lot of that back in the early
right like you don't need to do that
like better than jesus
78 d some dude's like hey hey
hey hey i'm doing christmas music yeah
[ __ ] you homie yeah
he's off the eggnog jesus christ yeah
yeah that is weird it's just weird to
wake up one day and be like you know
what i could [ __ ] capitalize on
some of this x-mix music
it's just a weird i don't know but
there's not a big market in it there's
not too many people on the vision board
be like christmas music
i don't know i think nelly did a
christmas album did he i think he did
nelly was great doing crossovers
he did a
tim
question no who do you do the florida
georgia line maybe there was one with a
jet that's all i remember it might i
think it was fgo it might have been it
might have been it might have been tim
mcgraw i think you're right it might
have been different i think it's in
mcgraw i can i get a picture in my head
i was thinking about us thinking about
me only just a dream is that it or am i
just yeah right we got computers
it was only just a dream yeah people
love shooting music videos on a jet way
just something about the open land
yeah i'm just trying to think of that
song again think about us was it him and
tim mcgraw
it was only just a dream
over and over again over and over again
over and over again
i keep picking we're talking about 149
million views that's big
and i'll say this
two of them could be mine
two male or just two in general here's
what i don't now here's what i want to
know
oh and they look they really i love how
they stop it right there does tim mcgraw
have a bunk bed yeah let's see that's
what i'm they made a lot of this really
first of all they put that skull cap on
tim mcgraw which that that's pretty hard
little kid rock ask it feels hard it
just feels like they're really trying to
merge artists right you know right so
what did they do for nelly to country
him out a little bit oh well let's see
if we can see nellie's packing some
copenhagen just drag that thing over
there just so we can see nelly just we
don't even need to hear it that's when
the saint louis ramsey is still there
they put him in front of the brick
building that's kind of country
no
brick i feel like is
from
oh they're touching belt buckles okay
yeah let's see right there there we go
they're touching that's the close-up on
belt buckles
oh the side kick now there they so to
get nelly really hyped up they put that
big belt buckle on them yeah they put
that flavor flav they really put it
right there that's how they locked him
in for this song and then they got a
picture of faith hill right there and
then nelly
is that his wife or
i wanna say sierra
who's sierra i don't see her at a party
one really she's a fox
when that song uh there was a song that
our school dances you had to be hands
touch one two step you had to be your
arms length away so tell me about that
but when oh so what do you mean so like
in like eighth grade for our dances
there was like chaperones and you had to
be one arm length away because that was
you know social distance him for when
you were horny you know
one arm's laying away semen's the
original cove
she's spreading everywhere dog but
when sierra's one two step or uh goodies
goodies that [ __ ] when that would come
out everybody would break the arm
barrier people
that i mean that was like the first time
my brain heard something i was like oh
[ __ ] me
to do who is that guy
i think it's petey pop
i know what i did
freak a leak wasn't that was that
cookies no
goodies hoodies clothes but when that
came on that was the first time my body
really felt something you know i
remember the first porn i ever googled
boobs.com that was the original but the
second time i really felt something was
when goodies came on at the school dance
and that was big that was everybody all
the chaperones were like you guys are
doing the freak dancing get them away
but yeah they always try to break it up
somebody blow a whistle
turn the lights off come out the clock
yeah they had air horns yeah exactly
it's like you're lying yeah exactly your
shirt's off you're sweating yeah that
was the first time oh that was crazy
dude school dances man i remember one
time going to pick this girl up uh oh
freak a leak was that it freakily was a
uh no goodies is there a song called
goodies goodies
series had jams
yeah just go just uh
no just goodies my good
goodies i think's your goodies
goody sierra oh with petey pablo
yeah i think that that's the same photo
on the nightstand no the second one down
it is damn look at me i know my [ __ ]
dude
there we go subliminal messaging nelly
is horny or really dating probably did
they date i'm wondering oh no
yeah it's all good i don't think we can
play it anyway can we
okay yeah regardless i'm playing in my
mind a little bit right now but that's
but right that was like the school dance
stuff was uh
this was even who'd you go with
i think you just went with homies
[Laughter]
but
like eighth grade dances you kind of
just showed up and then you just kind of
like like in movies you'd sit at the
wall and you'd wait to make eye contact
with but in high school that's when you
would ask the girl
oh really we had no i went on our school
it was big you had to get asked or ask
at like seventh grade wow and they had
different dances man they had sadie
hawkins city hawkins okay then they had
this one dance where they made a big
shirt yeah they would sew the shirt
sleeves together it was like what was it
called parachute love lock or something
you see how many people you could fit in
there no you had it was you and your
date so y'all were like a big circle you
know by the sleeves yeah yeah and so you
were um
it might have been spring fling or
something so that would have these
special shirts made for everybody and
you had to be like locked in like this
yeah so all night you were kind of
locked in how did you pee uh
your pants you just come out
that'd be a weird place to get it
on your back and do it
like something [ __ ] unknown but then
she's laying on her stomach and then
she's going out the honorable one oh
yeah yeah no i uh i remember one year i
asked a girl uh to homecoming in a
tiffany's box but it just said uh
homecoming
on a piece of paper and then i opened it
like i was proposing and then she
friendzoned me that night i went in for
the kiss and she gave me the cheeks hit
me with the cheek i mean i was yeah i
was way out of my league this girl she
she was like the girl who had like the
the tits in town
she was like she was
you ask anybody both of them yeah you
guys see anybody about uh in camera
california about uh about christina i
mean she had the bags on her bang bangs
bags were fully charged but
byron
yeah i love them
yeah but she was awesome and but i was
like i was really stepping outside of my
britches you know oh dude i remember
this one girl man i think her name was
noel right good titty name and she had
i don't know her whole body was tits
yeah her whole body was just made out of
tit dude every part of her body was hit
you graze her hand a little bit you're
like oh [ __ ] oh
areola even a high five felt like it had
milk in it you know what i'm saying she
just was all ted yeah
and i remember somehow
he agreed to go to a dance with me i
i even remember when i asked her i was
so i was on mushrooms when i asked her
and i got so hyped after she said yes i
ran and jumped over a chain-link fence
and cut my
literally cut my hand open and my
stomach opened did you grip it like you
were pole vaulting a little bit no i
just tried to jump completely straight
into it oh it's so stoked oh cause
you're on mushrooms yeah i was like i'm
gonna show her this cool trick you know
what i'm saying she knows she's dealing
with a savage name and that was tet girl
so anyway i healed up and we went to the
dance
and uh
and one of my hands was still pretty
bandaged up you know my hand where i got
cut pretty well was pretty banned
so i remember she let me like kind of
get one of those tits out boy and i'm
just batting that thing yeah like
mayweather [ __ ] just throwing rice on it
that's what will heal the hand oh it was
some you know yeah some canelo bro yeah
yeah
right just a little little batting
practice with that tito oh yeah and um
and then later on at night she like
we're at my friend's house and we're
sitting there and they had a pool table
and i'm like trying to get like trying
to get her underpants off a little with
the mitt on oh it was so hard and i
think she kept thought uh
that i was like tapping her on this like
i was trying to ask her a question yeah
yeah cause she would i could see that
like what you know because i kept every
time i'd like kind of touch her with
them yeah you should add her like
seductively like undo the wrap on your
hand with her teeth or something going
around
if going back in time dude i would do it
so different but i got so nervous
because she was so she was the hot she
was the she was just a living tit
and i got so nervous that i just kind of
i just fell apart and
uh
how's she doing now i'm sure she's
beautiful and has a family same to it
like most of the people that i know or
most of the you know like most women
that i stalk occasionally at night on
facebook yeah every once in a while your
dad will see how they're doing for kids
arkansas yeah the evil were saying
yeah they call him you a natural tick
guy or a uh implant
well
implants
there was a rocky time for implants
there was a time where they came out
real hard they were startled
oh yeah i remember uh there was a
stripper in north carolina uh
green greenville greensboro one of them
probably greensboro maybe but she she
told me she got hers for like 300 off
and uh i was like i don't think that's
something you want to cut
you know corners on
they were they were still good but they
they kind of look like um you ever
remember those old school dvd or like
dvd stacks would be like a tube in the
middle then all the the dvds were on it
it kind of looked like she had two of
those and was like a little bit on top
too because it kind of looked like a
nipple
they were solid but i know what you mean
they were like
there was some real yeah there was a lot
of uh some of them were very
they're like shifty like you kind of
like like you know how people can like
move like kneecap yes like you could do
that with their tits yeah some of them
you could yeah it seemed like you could
kind of like you could almost um
shift gears yes yes
like you were driving an 18 wheeler yeah
there was some real dude there was a
girl i met one time in
raleigh uh north carolina great city and
her
breasts were like these they were almost
like a
you ever seen like a um
like a baby have like a poop diaper you
know yeah
and if you squeeze it it stays in that
shape oh tempurpedic yes but it didn't
go back it did her tits would kind of if
you squeeze him there was some day there
yeah i don't know what is tempur-pedic
whole deal about putting wine on the bed
and just jumping
i think a lot of couples that's like the
highlight of their just putting
somewhere low on the corner and getting
after it if you never left town that's
uh that's your summer olympics honeymoon
right there
grab the franzia we're getting after it
oh i think it's a lot of people yeah and
then some yes so you know
i don't know i think i think if i was a
girl i'd have really weird tits
i think i just have weeds i think you
have a very model body for a young woman
yeah that a complicated girl recently
that had a body like you was it me
i don't know what type of body i'd have
i think i'd be the the girl with no ass
but like knockers
just like you know with them
yeah just bagged up ready to go
yeah i think i would just have
but i don't know i think i'd have weird
aerials that's my biggest insecurity
i i know
your body style you're not gonna have
wheat you think you'd have big areolas
but you know the ones that kind of just
like disintegrate into the sea of of
skin yeah they fade out yeah i think i'd
have those
but i kind of like those you know it's
fun you don't know where it starts or
stops kind of like the ocean
yeah where's the atlantic where's the
pacific just that incoming outgoing tide
like sometimes it looks like a little
more yeah
a little more areola do now that i think
about it i remember the first time i met
you i was hosting uh it's like 2017 in
oxnard and you had your shirt off it was
after a show and you just had your shirt
off and you ordered
uh what's a tuna called sashimi you
ordered a ahi tuna salad but you're like
i don't want the salad and i've never
forget that moment and the waitress was
so confused she's like so you don't want
the salad you're like no i want the
salad but i just want the tuna and she
was so confused and you had your shirt
off for that [ __ ] yeah and that's all i
remember
savage yeah and that was my first savage
move it was really savage and then you
said something after you're like i can't
believe anybody can just have babies and
then that was it
and still can't
but i was just like this is double power
moves shirt off well actually triple
shirt off ahi tuna
just opinions yeah i was just like yeah
man so what do you want me to say up
there about you
what were you were you for you were
performing there i was just hosting i
was hosting oh that's out in oxnard that
levity live out there i was just hosting
the show that's probably four years ago
five it was a while ago yeah and
i forget who was featuring but i just
remember like it was a two show thing
and it was like in between the two shows
you were just eating ahi tuna with your
shirt off living but bro you had the
shirt off today watching christmas
movies
maybe i'm living wrong yeah you could be
maybe i'll leave him wrong i could be
wearing too many skins man that's maybe
what it is um yeah my flight got
canceled dude uh
and that kind of i always get no i
always wonder when my flight gets
canceled if that's god looking out for
me or not yeah i think my flight
yesterday was an old plane it had the
the tvs that stick out of the seat like
the brick ones like almost look like a
thermostat a little bit it's like a tan
box yeah it was delta but it was the
pilot was pissed i had my foot on the
wall and he goes that's not a very uh he
goes this is not a very mature thing to
do take your foot off wow he he said
like it was his plane which look i
understand he's flying that [ __ ] by all
means but he said it like he like pulled
it out of the garage like he was
collector delta 747 well it's also
that's a very subtle way of saying
you're in first class also i do want to
say that
you know you know when you're flying
first class from la to nashville it's a
that's a 300 upgrade but i was feeling
myself first weekend back of uh you know
i was feeling myself a little bit
there's only one place on the plane you
could put your foot on a wall or the
very back
the stewardess you just got it up on the
coffee maker
yeah i mean the stewardesses are getting
fight they're all on their phone out
there listening to loud ipads and [ __ ]
watching coco melon and [ __ ] yeah it's
crazy it's definitely a different vibe
out there now in the skies yeah but you
know i uh i feel like they nobody wanted
to be there the pilot was like pissed he
was there because somebody used you know
pilots use the same front bathroom as
everybody else oh yeah they'd have one
in the cockpit it's so weird that oh my
ex-girlfriend's dad was a pilot and they
used to urinate into a jug up there i
think like a folger's can would make
sense
well
that's probably old school but like
they're real old some guy brings a metal
candy urinated yeah but the folgers now
are plastic so i feel like that's
bananas yeah it's not good for the
environment if a plane goes down that
see i just wonder is god looking out for
me is like like could this plane go down
right i no i feel that
i do ever think that that could happen
do you ever feel like
because when i was younger it happened a
lot
getting canceled uh getting cancelled by
god dying in a plane crash i do i had
that fear yesterday because the pilot
was i've never seen a pilot piss and he
was an older gentleman i've never seen
somebody like mad mad and it's like
we're about to take off you know
somebody
rub him off a little bit or give him
some cbd gummies because he was on one
and i was like this is the guy in charge
of the plane you know that's the guy
everybody else is [ __ ] like think
about how you drive right think about
how you drive when you're having a tough
day you're you're [ __ ] you see red
lights as a suggestion you're like maybe
so i'm like on takeoff i had this weird
euphoric feeling i was like what if he
just did a nosedive
what if what if today's a day is like
you know that is once dude think about a
pilot
you really are you're that you you
really have the ability to say who who
who how many do you want god yeah you
know in your hands how many you want god
and also ten dozen yeah i got ten
dollars
this [ __ ] got his feet on the board
so let's take him out delta should be
who is the pilot's wife how is she doing
that's what i'm saying taking care of
them they got to be treating these
people
i salute uh pilots when i get off i go
thank you for the flight because
everybody nobody makes eye contact with
the turning they say thank you to the
flight attendants which i get that but
like the pilots are the you know like
salute i'll lean in there and yes i'll
say kiss him on the cheek good job
fellas yeah or ma'am yeah right and i'll
say that even at the same fellas or
ma'am and they know that they don't yeah
and even the lady if she's a female
pilot she wants to be called fella
she got a little more gray hair than
usual you're like i see what you're
doing with that toupee i see what you're
doing yeah some women just want to go so
hard that you they want you to call them
man right fella but that's i feel like
pilots don't get enough uh credit also
if i was a pilot i would be like i would
go on the intercom be like i sure would
love some starbursts right now
and then i'd wait for somebody to be
like come bring it up and then if nobody
does i'd be like y'all want turbulence
little [ __ ] rival rattle
what do you think
like dude one this guy dan gilbert you
said the best joke and he still has it
because it's his gym he said turbulence
is a
button that rich that people in first
class press
i wish i had that yesterday i want to
[ __ ] with everybody back there row 23
y'all awake yet
they should have
or if you're playing those games where
everybody on the plane can play and you
win you should be able to get a little
remix them a little oh yeah just see
what's going on stir them up a little
bit yeah i i always think that like if
my phone's not on airplane mode like
it's it's gonna [ __ ] some up i but but
then i've been on flights where i forget
to turn it off and it's the same flight
so that's something i want to know is
airplane mode a hoax
you know a lot of things have i think
they used to have like
probably
you know back in the day they probably
what was before that
before airplane mode yeah who's turned
it off
or right then they had air they'd like
silent mode cause airplane mode's such a
specific thing i don't even know what it
does it just blocks
calls i guess it's supposed to stop the
signal but nothing can stop the signal
see my phone i saw my phone the other
night get up and get something to drink
like this thing's been offered my phone
just get a mountain dew code red right
now
yeah i don't know but that's the thing i
i like are you a superstitious guy oh
yeah yeah so i'm like that too like
before i take off i'll be like like i
won't turn my airplane mode back on
until the wheels touch the ground
because i don't want to [ __ ] up airwaves
you don't want to be in that bag you
know i really like when i'm when i'm
traveling
i like to have something on my feet you
know you see some people do barefoot
traveling
and most of these people are indigenous
people or uh
i don't want to say homeless but could
you know
could be homeless
but all birds are what i like to wear
when i fly i like to have them all birds
on
they just have a
comfortable it's a comfortable shoe it's
it's classy but it's also relaxing it's
like you're
it's almost like uh
it's like you're in the library but you
could also
go for a nice jog if you needed to
that's what they do
that's right they got a new shoe the
wool dasher mizzle
our weather repellent performance
running shoe
the first shoe of its cus of its kind
sustainably made made from real stuff
natural materials bone and fur
with a low environmental impact on the
planet
that's right
the wood the wool dasher mizzle
from all birds get them dub dms baby
don't let winter storms put a damper on
your run or your foot grab a pair of the
weather repellent wood wool dasher
missiles wool dash or missiles
there's just something about it i
haven't i haven't worn that style yet
the style i have is more i think of a
comfort based style
but this winter keep your feet cozy and
dry
with the all birds wood dasher wool
dasher
missiles
discover your perfect pair at
allbirds.com today that's
allbirds.com
that's right i wear about a 10 and 10
and a half and i enjoy them
you know people are trying to lose
weight right now people are trying to
save money
people are trying to use less do less
things quit cigarette
maybe quit doing sex or something
outside of their marriage people trying
all kind of things new year's resolution
well
at the top of my list is learning a new
language
[Music]
with babel the language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions not only is learning a new
long-wise
fun and engaging hobby
but you can use it while you check
traveling more
from your 2022
uh
list of resolutions the whole babble
process
is addictive it's fun it's easy
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a language on the go
that's right with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages
spanish french italian german
start your new language learning journey
today with babel b-a-b-b-e-l
right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you can
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com use promo code
t-h-e-o that's b-a-b-b-e-l dot com code
theo babble language for life
yeah sometimes i think when the flight
gets canceled that that's like i just
want you know and maybe it's egotistical
to think that it's like oh is that no is
that part of god saving my life because
i would rather that than like you know
when you get you like board the plane
like oh we gotta work on the engine for
like two to three hours like that
doesn't make me feel better like just
lie to me be like the pilot had to go
get some egg bites from starbucks right
like like when they're like oh we're
working on the engine we'll be good in a
sec like i don't want to know that
yeah but i
it used to be dicer you would hear the
dude in there work and you'd see a guy
with an oil can i don't know it said oil
on it oh yeah yeah he was a cartoon
figure
what is going on
i don't want to know anything about like
like i literally i i edit a lot of my
videos on flights because i don't want
to think about the fact that i'm like
just in the air like when my phone dies
and like the it's just like the tv on
the plane like not working and all i
have is my thoughts that's the worst
flight of my life i'm just sitting there
thinking really i'm just i have a lot of
anxiety in that sense of like
you know my whole childhood was that we
didn't have because then phones yeah i
mean i don't the [ __ ] i did growing up
probably like sudoku puzzles or some
dumb [ __ ] or like made it tic-tac-toe
but i like i like i need to do something
so i don't think about the fact that i'm
just like in the sky right it's yeah
yeah i guess it's interesting i guess
part of the thing of a flight is to try
to trick people you think they try to
trick you more to thinking that you're
in the sky like on the inside of the
windows draw have like a forest or
something yeah or like a glass like
bottom floor just like but like one
aisle just one aisle and you get to pay
extra for it like row 13 you just get to
see below you
that's kind of hard bro
in the [ __ ] flights with the feet
one time we were landing somewhere and
it was a prop plane right so what does
that mean it was just a small plane
oh the connecting flight ones were scary
yeah it was a real small one so
you see the propeller something hit uh
bounce down the side of the plane
because there's only a couple things it
could be you're in the air you know bird
bird
alien kevin yeah a smaller plane
person you know loose person skydiver
yeah so i'm like what so everybody's
like what the [ __ ]
you know some guy's like i know what it
is some guy
there's always some guy who looks over
he's like yeah that's actually just the
tropical storm of the stratosphere
shut up everybody there's four jack
daniels bottles spilling out from his
waist so did you ever find out what it
was
we got out bro and no joke in the front
um in one of the um
rotors right
there was a
bird
things mangled
like a um
wings
enough of a wing enough of one where you
knew what happened oh no it was like a
mallard
no no it was bigger than that i would
think it was probably pelican or
damn i mean yeah because usually to to
rattle the plane but i will say some of
those connecting flights where you got
to like you land in like seattle but you
got to go to spokane and it's one of
these like mountainy flights yeah and
you can still see the propeller on the
it's like an uncovered propeller you
ever see in one of those
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about
right so this was one where something
got you know oh and part of me wonders
because i felt us go off course a little
part of me wonders if one of the old
dogs up there was like you know what see
how theo's doing i'm about to well no
i'm gonna hit something oh oh he's like
i'm done
cause how hard would it be if you're
having a bad day you're tired you know
and you're just a mallard your wife's
doing some you know it's something with
your husband because there's a lot of
gay pilots now too
which
i'm fine with it but it's just like do
we know enough about their relationships
to know if the guy can if something goes
bad
like i feel like we know enough where
like if a straight man in a in a
straight relationship if something gets
real bad the guy
there's been enough study where he's
maybe not going to crash he's a gay dude
or gay woman just going to be like you
know i just
i would love to see a pilot with a mood
ring on it you know but like one they
don't know about one they don't know
about but if i walk on and it's like
blue or green i'm like okay they're
feeling all right but it's like bright
red or yellow yeah we might need uh we
might need to delay this a few hours go
get some some chamomile or something
would these there should be intel on the
pi so you can look even on the app it's
like hey you know
uh
like you know samuel rhonda whoever the
pilot is yeah they're doing yeah because
even on uber it says like their favorite
activities the parks favorite sports
team i want to know more about the pilot
yeah also i think like you know i'm sure
they have a lounge for pilots but like
they should have like the delta sky club
should be four pilots right like this
place where they can just post up crush
a couple michelobs
i don't know but i uh i don't know if
you can drink i know globe
okay one yeah yeah or a non-alcoholic
one just to feel like they're doing
something yes
just to give them that like that edge
mentally that's actually never mind
that's a terrible idea i don't know man
now you got me wanting it yeah you just
just won cause i bet if i'm a pie
there's no way some of them aren't
drinking man one of my ex-girlfriends
that my childhood girlfriend dad was a
pilot or he and he had a couple extra
families and everything dude he had like
it was crazy bro it was really just you
know being the best pilot you could be
oh yeah if i'm gonna be landing if i'm
sleeping here after year yeah he's
pumping yeah i'm i'm having some kids
yeah well i've met people at my shows
yeah like on like a friday night they're
all like a little hammered like yeah man
we're all pilots at the local airport
and they're all like hammered hammered
and i'm like they're not gonna be
hammered in the morning but like a
little hungover a little on edge yeah
because here's the thing you can't
assume that pilots have a magical power
maybe they do maybe part of going
through the air force and going through
flight school they're like they start to
weed out the people who have really bad
hangovers i bet they do yeah can you be
hungover and in the military
yeah dude that's the military okay
it's just called to you
but i just feel like they just plow
right through mentally you know they
just go hurrah and they [ __ ] beat the
[ __ ] out of that hangover
yeah still
they got it though they they have the
hangover to beat the [ __ ] but they just
cruise right past it yeah um
what uh do you i i you don't strike me
and i don't mean this to be offensive to
you but you don't strike me as a kind of
guy that would survive in a
plane crash type of scenario you are
correct
i don't think i would do well i was
thinking about that yesterday i'm fine
if i'm going down what am i doing am i
dapping up the homie next to me what am
i doing am i reaching a couple rows back
just to tell an elderly man like
thank you for your service i don't know
thank you for hearing just being old
he's putting up with millennials i just
got out of jail he's probably
what if he's a pedophile
teardrop tattoo uh yeah i don't think i
would do well i mean i don't think i'd
do well in a lot of tough scenarios you
know really
but say you crash right you crash yep
what is some of your first moves when
you're on the ground these are these are
the things you got oh well we're making
like
okay
but i am alive but like i'm a little
mangled
you're alive you're probably you're
doing a no how about this you're
pristine okay big word people were like
what oh i look good like fine i mean
literally like every movie action hero i
have like one star right here everything
yeah almost like better than when you
went in i looked like that dude in the
the insurance commercials what's his
name oh yeah yeah um
what's that guy's name
what first thing i'm doing
damn allstate guy oh uh yeah it's like
danger or something cool yeah danger
danger rick or something guys hot
first thing i would do what do you do
because this it's important the first
thing you do is important because you're
on an island you guys there's no police
coming over probably a couple weeks
wow
first thing i'm doing um
probably checking my phone
no
that's not being honest you can check it
it's that's not that's done
the worst is going to be some idiot on
the beach the whole time like trying to
get their phone to work like holding up
at the sun yeah shaking it's like asking
the stewardess can i get more coffee
this store just doesn't have an arm does
anybody yeah like anybody got boost
mobile nobody has nobody who's mobile in
general yeah uh realistically i think
i would probably try to get the youngest
people out of the plane of the crash
first but even that's weird here's on
the island you're yelling for babies
because they have the most potential in
life isn't because or you say
seniors and ladies first i think is it i
think so unless it's changed maybe this
is where the difference i think is just
like
and
this is where things are changing
save the babies yeah but you can't just
be young where's the kids at a little
weird in 2022. where's the kids the
first thing you land you go where's the
kids at they're like all right you
should not if you just saluted the guy
behind you that's the first thing you
absolutely say where's the kids at i
don't know what are you who you saving
first
what's the first thing you're doing
the first thing you got to do is be able
to provide food for everybody where oh
like on the island yeah trevor okay the
first thing you have to be able to do is
provide food for everybody because
people need to know if you're a leader
or not that's true because if you're not
a leader out of the gate then i think
you're you risk you take on a lot of
risk
uh i don't think you need to be like
insane alpha no you know you don't want
to fake it
you take the shirt off i'll probably
take your shirt off
or i'd rip this shirt off just to assert
dominance maybe just one sleeve or
something no i think if you're gonna
here's what you don't want to happen you
don't want to try to rip your shirt off
and you can't get it off you can't do it
i've seen that happen on many frat
parties it always it always is caught on
the collar part because it's different
stitching up there well yeah and the
collar won't break yeah people were like
and then they just like pretend like
that was their plan the whole time yeah
like we know you're doing thorbin we
know what you're doing
already yeah i mean i don't know i i
think um
so you gotta feed everybody so the first
thing you have to get is probably you're
gonna get have to get some small ground
game so you're going to want to do
probably squirrel is easy to hunt
pheasant is one of the easiest things to
pheasant is oh pheasant's really easy if
you've just cut a crop or something
pheasant's wall i know what a pheasant
is but also what is a pheasant
i've seen them little [ __ ] are they
um
they're like not squirrels but they're
not chipmunks a pheasant is a oh it's a
bird so you're not it's a small bird
it's a small chicken i grew up in
california my whole life i don't
understand that i know pigeons and
seagulls oh dude oh these little guys oh
yeah these [ __ ] are legit baby
they're basically like a mexican they
almost look kind of mexican honestly
um they all have a nice little like
diamond chain on them yeah i mean they
look like one of them you know like the
mexican guy that comes in with the
like the uh mariachi yes that's what
they they seem like they have that sort
of they look fast circumstance about it
are they not fast i feel like catching
that would be a little hard
uh pheasants one of the easiest things
to catch if you are if you're stuck
somewhere and you need to cook for
people i i already i can tell if you
you're going to be like more of a sous
chef you're going to be like the guys
coconuts because they can't move
yeah birds got legs and wings coconuts
none of those they're just chilling you
don't really have an option yeah so
coconuts is good unless he could get
some coconuts i think another thing you
could prepare for people if you want or
capture form squirrels
um
what else is something that's easy
rabbits is a little trickier than you
would think right if you could get
turtle that's an easy thing but you're
gonna have to be able to get it open
yeah here's the thing or you just use a
turtle shell to like chop a coconut bag
on you don't hurt the turtle but you use
its back as like a cutting board yeah
you can't be the guy who's like let's
don't hurt the turtle in a plane crash
you gotta cause it 2022 man that's me
that's our millennials dude we're
[ __ ] we're like let's get the turtle
but let's not like i'll sacrifice the
coconut shell but i'm using it for shoes
after
i need to use everything yeah i'm the
stationary guy right there right there
look at that and that dove is a
beautiful bird man i saw i've actually
had dove they had two brothers lived by
me at my old apartment complex and they
was always grilling dove outside
grilling duff
i thought doves were always white no
um what are the what are the ones they
release a few no there's a church dough
that funeral does doves
where do those birds go after funerals
you're also talking
oh they just let them go and they just
do they like track them down there's
usually a handler that's like about
probably a quarter mile away and they
fly to that guy oh really yeah there's a
guy usually parks at like a
and they know a strip mall or whatever
they got like a it's all uh my iphone
type type thing
i don't know if they have that they used
to have homing pigeons where oh yeah um
bobby kennedy was on and he talked about
when he was a kid they would take homing
pigeons and they would put him on the
train
and they would ask the conductor to let
him go let them go when they got to like
virginia yeah you know
and then whoever's homing pigeon flew
back first that's who won it was like
him
tough mudder but for the sky yeah i mean
they've been doing this forever the
carrier pigeons birds are great at this
birds
you need to prepare a dove for somebody
you know how to cook a dove
grilling i guess
you could grill yeah i think it'd be
easy it's probably gonna have to have
fire
squirrel what is this animal easiest oh
this is this article is easiest animals
to hunt for beginners
that's you
it's his eye
dove squirrel girl there you go pheasant
coming in there we go what does it say
there pheasant or excellent
game bird that bird only has one leg
he's all ready to take out
you want to play a game of hopscotch and
then he just falls over and you just
throw him in a chokehold
oh yeah that bird is ready to party what
are pheasants they're just homies of
chickens they're just in that same realm
you know that's a great statement man
let me see right homies of chickens is
that actually what uh webster's
dictionary says remember to be patient
and have fun with your hunting adventure
hunting pheasant is a great pastime it's
especially fun to do with your children
if you're getting them into hunting at
an early age
there you go wow
11 people down voted that so that's 11
people who had to tough time cousin
pheasants
really me yeah if you go to the article
11 people down voted it so i was one of
them but 38 we're like [ __ ] yeah
thumbs up brother
no they put easy to hunt that's what
they're at
yeah but that's 11 people that were like
it was a tough tuesday for me
yeah
yeah so let's go down a little bit more
raccoon i could see that they're already
in the trash can you just close the lid
and they're kind of done for yeah but
you didn't but then you have to be
willing to set fire outside of the can
and watch them and let them burn in
there
it's kind of like that using that green
egg trigger yeah have you ever used that
yeah yeah oh those are great the trigger
types or the the little pellets
yeah i mean that's definitely a white
that's a white trash traeger right there
but you set fire outside of a garbage
can as a raccoon in it
i mean you're eating in two hours but it
is it's got a good seasoning it's kind
of like a cask iron in there you know
it's all the different years and years
of food and season that's in there
that's a good point man not bad a good
point and let's look at animal number
five too to see what animal was
ducks make sense bread all you need duck
is basically a mentally handicapped uh
bird let's be honest bro
i mean because birds are supposed to be
flying and you see something sitting in
the water yeah it's almost like if you
ran up on a couple dudes like bobbing
for apple but with your fists yeah i
think you ran up on a couple dudes they
sitting in the water you're like oh
these dudes just coming in light i feel
like birds are almost looking for it
ducks are
ducks sorry yeah i meant that birds in
general and that's enough i don't want
to know all of them let's don't see all
of them i want to save some for the
people at home well just to think for
myself too i don't want to sometimes
like knowing you don't want to see that
animal in public and be like that's a 7
right there i'm not going to go for it
well yeah and we know when we know
enough now to either be able to survive
or not survive i think lizards would be
number one d but there's not enough well
to catch there's not enough meat on them
yeah
could you do it though you think you
could survive it no
i don't think so damn i mean there's
only so many know in your heart i'm
asking you seriously uh i i mean i would
give it a a solid try but you know i get
mad if my coffee's too hot at starbucks
that's not the type of guy who's gonna
make it in wilderness right you know and
you gotta be willing to sacrifice
somebody immediately the first thing you
need to do is take somebody else's life
in order to show that you are
dominant yeah i don't think so because i
remember one time i was really drunk in
college and i tried to fight a guy and i
went to go smash a glass bottle and the
glass bottle didn't break
so i don't think that i would that was
my you're like i'm just recycling yeah
right that was my t-shirt tara it didn't
break and and after that you know i play
that back in my head a lot when i think
about alpha situations manly [ __ ] and i
and i just don't think you know i would
give it a good go but i would piggyback
on other people's like i would become
friends with the guy who could catch a
boar right and then i'd be like bro i
got the cranberry sauce hey darren yeah
exactly i'm bringing like accents yeah
you know oh you need coconuts i got you
bro let me get a lamb chop for a coconut
right right let me trade let me do
something here right i mean i so yeah
you would definitely you would have more
of a skill set of a um i'll like shout
people out on instagram probably but
i'll shout you out for you know a couple
yeah i mean you could chisel it into a
tree
like that when i was a when i was like
real young that was our instagram was
like writing you know i love you know
wrong you know that was an instagram
story you just like put a lock on a
fence with your initials and you're like
theo was here
it was crazy different people do that
people do just put locks on
what do they do the initials of them and
like a lover and put it on like a bridge
yeah you ever done that
i've never done that i'm trying to think
of was there a young thing that you did
when you were a child like a young love
like some like
thing you guys did together like name um
oh bro i got one what is it in my my old
hometown room on the ceiling there's
like those little like neon like
glow-in-the-dark stars oh yeah yeah and
they're still there
but and they should be
the best is when they're still there
when you're 30 dude oh bro i was back
over the holidays you turn the lights
off smoke a little bit of that kush and
you look up and you're like is that
[ __ ] orion's belt
just a ceiling fan but when i was
younger in like sixth grade i would like
name the stars after the girls like
crushes on i'll be like that's krista
ooh
and and that like you know you're
listening to me like he was [ __ ]
[ __ ] but that like like there was
something about that i was like damn
i just it brought me it was like hearing
goodies by sierra for the first time
every time
that was one thing that i that i
that i think i would that i did you know
that's beautiful you got anything like
that i got there was this girl chrissy
that i was in love i don't know if i was
in love with her but she lived close
enough for me to be horny about
which was the same thing you know what
i'm saying but i was blocked yeah oh god
i remember just everything about her
just
just god made just
just made semen want to climb out of my
body yeah you know i want to take a peek
oh like a gopher seeing if his
groundhog's there or not oh you'd
probably hear a team and just come up to
the top of my tongue and just look out
you know say it like roll back down or
they go get the home he's like you got
to see this [ __ ] yeah with us right
homie let's ride and did and you just
thought about her or
you
you guys went in love with her i was in
love with her and you went on a couple
dates with her we were children they
didn't have dates they didn't have any
we played it huh play date no no no we
live near there's no play dates in my
[ __ ] neighborhood dude people were
getting molested
so i i lived in a very uh suburban town
yeah this is way different dude played
age you know juice box guy down the
street used to bang this substitute
teacher that lives in our neighborhood
this kid basically he was 16. yeah and
then he would chase us
around in the church like field with his
car in his car and try to hit us
that was a date right there that was a
play date
yeah
so basically this dude was getting
molested by an older woman and then
since we called him out
like uh
you just he would try to run over so he
just turned that [ __ ] into grand theft
auto just a little bit of gta in real
life yeah there was no play date don't
you want
one kid that
drooled all the time
that we would all kind of spend time
with but i think that was more like a
cry for help i think than anything but
um
i was i gonna tell you about oh so
oh but i was in love with this girl
chrissy bro god
and i remember she had part of her tooth
was chipped out yeah you know she had
that little baby lloyd christmas on her
you know love it and i remember always
looking for pieces of rock or shell when
i was like outside of the school house
like when they had uh oh all the gravel
yeah trying to find one that wouldn't be
like the cinderella story yeah did you
ever find that glass slipper yeah
uh i found a couple i remember
collecting five or six that were pretty
close yeah i showed her one time
somebody locked us in a room like you
guys need to get in there and [ __ ] you
know just some you know even better
rocks
probably some local 40 year old
the same guy driving around in the car
bro there was so many creeps man and did
any of them fit or not um
or did she like take any of them or she
like yeah i gave them all to her wow i
think she thought it was sweet i would i
think it's sweet now just hearing about
that you know i put it on a pukeshell
necklace
oh yeah i thought i had that ability to
make them necklace kits you know yeah
that was always if somebody if a girl
likes somebody a lot of time they would
get that necklace kid and put the thing
randy you know and spell it out yeah
we had a dumb one where if you take the
inside of like an aquafina water bottle
the cap it's like a plastic and you like
you can make the plastic a wristband and
the weird joke was like if they put it
on you and it broke you had to like make
out with them
oh really so you were always praying at
break you like tensing up your knuckles
you sneeze extra hard oh [ __ ] i guess we
gotta make out no mac but yeah the
inside of an aquafina cap there's like a
little rubber thing you can poke out the
center make a little wristband but you
see a kid like maybe a guy who like
probably has a couple of like
misdemeanors now but he'd have like
three wristbands on him growing up and
you're like dude [ __ ] got some puss
this morning
that was yeah i feel like growing up was
always just a way to flex you know just
like having a girl wear your football
jersey
you know you walk to school with a
hickey everybody wore tank tops on
hickey day we caught two dudes sucking
on each other's necks doing fake hickeys
on each other one time
yeah damn but had they not got caught
in case you haven't heard car and home
insurance is important
you got to ensure you know it's just the
way you could hedge your bets
and assume it won't get
stolen or damaged but
it's risk that's big risk if you
sleeping at night and you're doing
candles and you don't have any home
insurance baby dang
you riding the rails baby you riding uh
you know
you're on the devil's highway baby
and if you haven't heard
car and insurance rates are going up
this year that's why you got to turn to
the zebra
they can help you find the perfect
insurance
in just
minutes
the zebra compares car and home quotes
they're a comparer so they do the
comparing for you
you don't need to go sit at some spot
and a man's in there and he's showing
you this and showing you that
and he got you know trying to sell you a
little raffle ticket or something for
his son little cadbury egg or something
in fact the zebra saves people an
average of 922 a year on car and home
insurance combined plus they'll do it
all in just five minutes
i've had great experience getting good
insurance and making sure i'm insured
you know somebody break a window a
falcon hit your damn house or something
you want to be insured
you know if a damn pirate comes down
your chimney or something look times are
tough and things are different
save time and money a minute show your
support go to thezebra.com
t-h-e-o
get your free quote today
that's at the zebra.com slash theo just
go see how much you can save that's all
they're asking the zebra
you know everybody's trying to keep
their body healthy and their penis is
definitely part of their body
so you got to keep that root healthy you
got to stay root positive they call it
blue chew can help
blue chew
making waves and bringing more
confidence into the bedroom offering
that little chewable tablet
help men get stronger longer lasting
erection
if you don't do erection a lot you can
change it
blue chew is a unique online service
they deliver the same active ingredients
as viagra
and cialis
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of the discreet
[Music]
people on there no awkward conversation
no doctor visit
and they'll hit you with that package
baby that blue chew
and here's a special deal for our
listeners who want to dick up
try blue chew free when you use our
promo code theo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping that's b l u
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w dot com
promo code t-h-e-o to receive your first
month free and we thank blue chew for
sponsoring the podcast
do you think in the future i think in
the future everybody do you feel like
more everybody's just going to be
just kind of ambisextrous like
everybody's just going to be yeah i feel
like it's going to be a charcuterie
board of [ __ ] it's a little bit of
everything yeah i like that i like some
of this if i'm drunk a little bit of
that right if i'm high i don't want
anything yeah i just want myself
uh yeah i mean it's just like
i feel like that's where it's definitely
because i think you used to need me just
men and women to do sex
because you needed to reproduce life
needed reproduction right but now they
got enough people got enough that that
that box is checked and i i mean i just
i found out about what a surrogate was
a year ago
what what do you mean by that like like
when somebody else holds your baby for
you uh
this is a true thing i said it on my
podcast but i i thought stiff socks this
sucks baby yes sir um but i thought the
dude [ __ ] like like let's say uh
miranda is the surrogate she's gonna
hold the baby i thought the dad like put
it in her i thought he like [ __ ] her
but it's not that at all they just shoot
it up in there
uh with like a you know
not a syringe but a syringe type of
field so you thought the dad went though
dad and wife oh he's got a stranger and
the dad went out i was like why wouldn't
you want to surrogate that's [ __ ]
well it would save two birds one bone
baby why wouldn't you well if you can
get your wife to agree you're gonna save
a lot of money because otherwise it's
like a hundred and ten grand i think to
go to a center yeah drop it off to the
whole thing
but i then that dude goes over there and
does it yeah what a creep that dude
right but that's also just weird i mean
and if you are a surrogate baby turn up
but it is weird to nut into a cup and be
like my son or daughter's in there and
then you just hope but i mean that's the
same thing as seeing a pregnant woman
you're like hey there's a there's a kid
in there
well i think we're we are getting past
the days where someone's going to carry
their own child yeah that's getting
weird like i think
by the time i have grandchildren and i
don't even have any children i'm also
[ __ ] lonely but
by the time
someone who knows me is younger they
it would be very weird to be like hey
look at this picture of when i was in my
ma i think that is starting it's going
to be you're going to be in a center
where you're going to be
completed it'll be like you don't need a
iphone charger to plug into the wall
every day you got a portable so you can
be like i got a portable stomach that i
can just have a kid in yeah
which you know can you take the carpool
lane with that probably but
gestation now if you love gestation you
could be like oh i'm old-fashioned i'm
going to have me a child right and
people are like you're crazy people that
still roll their own cigarettes you know
it'd be same type of people yeah i still
i it is mind-blowing to me that the body
hasn't been like uh like give me let me
get a part two like how we i agree we
got new iphones every other goddamn day
but how do i not have a drink holder in
my hands that aren't my hands and i know
my everyone's like oh your hands but
like sometimes you're holding enough
[ __ ] you're bringing up stuff in the car
you're like i need a i need a [ __ ] a
big gulp right here yeah you know
something hooks in between two of my
ribs right exactly
why do we gotta sleep for eight hours
every night you know where's the usbc
charger i can just plug in my ass right
get going i think we're getting close
man
yeah just some stuff seems a little
dated
we used to have tails as humans huh
did we really i believe so oh wow and
then just over time so i'm wondering in
the future over time what are we not
gonna have what are we gonna lose well i
think at that point you start to look at
aliens man and you look at aliens
and they're always the creature has big
eyes big brain a big head you know
cavern head
and uh
which was a nickname of some kid at our
school too when i was a kid actually
yeah he wasn't doing real well i mean he
passed away
so he wasn't smart enough for god to
keep alive but he was you know he was i
guess he was kind of handsome when they
[ __ ] dressed him up
but um a lot of fedora's on that boy oh
dude i went to school until the uh oh i
had a crazy store but um
they
had a lot of the special ed kids dress
up in suits one year to like
to like want like there was a new
teacher and he he's like we're going to
have all the boys are going to wear
suits and it was just like
yeah
it was just crazy
just to like impress the teachers just
to like like why are the special kids
all in suit like it was like did you
want a suit the next day
uh kind of makes me want to see it i
mean i think it hyped the game it
definitely hyped a little bit of fashion
at school yeah but that was good but i
don't i just think that overall i don't
know if it was like
you know it was just kind of a weird
move for them to do
but um
anyway what were we talking about
oh
kissing that girl
human tails what do we get what are we
gonna have in the future that we're not
gonna oh i'll tell you this oh so so
aliens if you look at if
if you look at aliens
how many humans are born with the tail
40
ever or like 40 cases so how many is
that 40 times what 24
so that's uh hunt 288.
that's per year there's 42.
now it's more than that
if you're born with a tail you keeping
it
now i am yeah i think 20 years ago you
said no yeah you know take his tail off
yeah i mean they'd [ __ ] burn you at
the stake you're a witch dude well back
in the day i think it was a real bad
luck but now it's more like yo you know
next you'll be in a video with willow
smith in an hour yeah that could also be
the extra hand i'm looking for you know
[ __ ] karen your groceries on that
[ __ ]
use it yeah what if your tail could just
arch your hair for you if you're busy
that'd be great bro
now what about this though
um
what are we talking about oh
i think if you look at aliens the head
the eyes are big
the thing their hands and legs there's
nothing even to him
like you look at an alien's body it's
always just like this long grit it's not
even used it's kind of just it's like
they fit they didn't finish drawing it
right and it's like they just don't use
them anymore the simpsons only got four
fingers is that true yeah people think
that's for like you know animation no
it's just laziness wow i [ __ ] forgot
to pull it on because that's the last
thing you draw nobody's gonna start an
animation with hands that's insane
start with hands
so like what is it what do you mean like
like you know you start drawing an anim
like a of a person with their face and
then you work down so hands are the last
thing you draw yeah it doesn't even
matter if you have three four yeah
four's good
oh yeah they got three middle and then
one one thumb but i like that it's kind
of cool you know i mean what do you
really need i mean some of these could
go which which which finger you taking
off first pinky
oh hold on
i would take this third finger out
is that the ring finger yeah that's a
ring finger
yeah
that's going to make it real hard for a
girl to be like you trying to you're
trying to be forever and you're like i
can't yeah i can't i would but the lord
told me not to yeah
that is funny
my ex my grandpa didn't have that finger
he got cut he worked in a saw mill in in
ohio and he was like doing uh something
down the line snipped it right off dude
my gran my dad had part of his finger uh
was taken off somebody slammed a door on
it that hard yeah not crazy
and doors that's back when doors were a
lot more made out of like lead and [ __ ]
just healthier doors
but
my school teacher also was missing this
part of his finger
listen what happened to him it was his
ring he was at the at a baseball game
for his son
and it hooked on the bleachers and he
stood up too
pulled
his finger off [ __ ] well whatever the
play was must've been good to stand up
that's the rbi right there
is that a gate like yelling and
screaming
yeah something right there you know you
know just get up for well maybe it could
have been a bad play too like what the
[ __ ] ref
lost the finger but uh
yeah what are we just talking about
again
what what mutation on a human you think
you could be good with and without in
the future finger lose one well it's
just when you look at aliens it's mostly
just the head and eyes at that point
it's just become this data center gotcha
the rest of these things are things you
don't even use anymore and i think
that's what a lot of things are becoming
it's like if you go to the store there's
a self-checkout there's only like two
dudes in there now yeah you know it used
to be a lady working as a nice now it's
two dudes in there you know one of
them's always hitting on the other one
everyone's not into it look it doesn't
work they're just wearing a blimpy
t-shirt where the [ __ ] yeah what i mean
does it make sense yeah what's the thing
you can take out of your body you don't
need uh liver yeah yeah that esophagus
uh [ __ ] in the back what is called
drums i know throat
your uh tonsils tonsils
there's so much stuff you don't need
but what but what i'm wondering is
but that's what i feel like aliens are
just people that aliens
they just come back to visit earth and
like oh this place is a dump and then
they jet i think they
it's almost like if your parents took
you to like
what would be like the shittiest place
hollywood boulevard to the library
libraries up there like if you go to the
library now you walk in there it's like
two homeless dudes
you know yeah coming on each other
probably harry potter books open you
know
yeah open bro but the chamber of secrets
is
looking in his own ass over the
periodicals you know like
basically
i'd stay for that
okay
you'd stay and look around you take your
kid in there to say hey look this is
what it used to be i'm gonna go to the
bathroom right right i'm gonna go film
this and send us a world star hip-hop
they can license it for 62.
but that's what aliens are that's why
they're not staying and hanging out
they're basically stopping by like the
oldest civilization it's like there's so
many more hype civilizations
out there 100 what's the first city you
think aliens would visit in the us
like if they're like bro you're going to
earth you've got to go to or like
where's they would probably go to tokyo
for sure you think i think you got it
yeah because they're aliens dude they're
like really hyped up and asians are
probably the closest to aliens i think
that that's
that's kind of even they know it
i think if an asian person sees an alien
they don't even i feel like they don't
even tell you
that's probably why that's the homie
that's what i'm saying dude so yeah if
you dialed in like that then
what what place in the in america you
can be a go like what city do you think
they would just like erica yeah but like
on a vacation like you know when people
are just like oh you gotta go down here
anymore trevor that's what i'm trying to
tell you they're not coming it's like
imagine if your parents kept taking you
to the sh it's almost like
i'm going to take you
you know i'm trying to think of a place
um
or when they first started out do you
think they were like you got to go down
to pcb when they first started out i bet
yes san diego probably was really cool
to see i bet new york city was probably
pretty good
but the buildings are so tall nobody can
even see the aliens when they can't find
them yeah yeah and you can't even land
them so it's almost like you want to get
in a more rural area santa fe new mexico
pennsylvania pennsylvania scranton
pennsylvania is basically just a
woodwork it's basically like
it's kind of like the santa fe of the
east you know i think you know
yeah it's very common i don't know if
anybody's ever yelled in pennsylvania
that's a lie people definitely yell
pennsylvania they wake up and school
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's some pretty good shows dude so
one of my favorite shows is out there in
wilkes-barre pennsylvania man yeah
well i mean you got pittsburgh you have
some good cities out there so
um oh yeah pennsylvania's pretty sick
man you got the dutch you got the amish
oh there they're full-on dude
you see a hundred percent amish out
there now what uh where are you going on
your tour and you got a tour coming up i
do dude i'm actually starting in uh new
orleans oh i'm excited for that yeah
which is interesting cause i've never
heard anything about new orleans for
comedy yeah i don't know and i got no i
don't have anything to tell you but
you're a louisiana boy yeah yeah but
they just don't have a it's not a real
comedy place you know yeah i will say
out of all the ticket sales out of the
it's like a 28 city thing it's like a
big thing that the the place is selling
the lease nala baby yeah because they're
like i don't give a [ __ ] i'm sucking
crawfish right now right they're doing
other stuff that's the thing about new
orleans you'll hear just some just as
much funny stuff from your neighbor
you'll hear there's just so many good
stories and so much like
there's more about music it's a real
city of like revelry and yeah to stop
into a place and watch some guy tell
jokes is very foreign to new orleans i
can see that and their style i think you
said it best like they already have
enough [ __ ] going on it's like you got
to go to a random place to really you
know grand rapids you got to go there
but for new orleans like there's always
[ __ ] popping off i need a good belly
laugh
i mean look if you're in new orleans
[ __ ] come on out but it's kind of all
over you know i'm kind of doing all over
the u.s a lot of florida uh
saint louis ohio [ __ ] portland
seattle i think it's just like 28 cities
that's awesome and congratulations
thanks man it's my first like big like
tour tour the rest have just been like
kind of little one-offs here and you
know just your the the typical weekends
at clubs but yeah this one is cool man
i'm really excited for it
what um
did you have a name for it yeah it's the
are you that guy tour oh yeah because
people always say that yeah i mean it's
just like it kind of started as like a
joke that my friends would say like at a
bar because like i love drinking just my
like hometown friends because they're
just they don't give a [ __ ] about any of
this stuff they still remember when i
got caught on a chain link fence trying
to hop it in like ninth grade
when i was in love
oh with the the barber no i was stuck on
a fence we missed a ufc fight we're
supposed to watch that night because i
got stuck on a fence for like an hour
and a half i just didn't i couldn't
commit
but that they'll bring that [ __ ] up one
time i tried to jump over a bush and i
tripped on the bush hedge like i ran and
just fell face first and a lady driving
by the car goes that's gotta hurt and
they still said it to me to this day i'm
like that's gotta hurt so i love
drinking with them but whenever we go
out a lot this is a safe area y'all were
in huh oh yeah people were driving space
sounds like safe [ __ ] yeah no very safe
hedges this was in front of a ralphs
yeah you know yeah i remember people
betting on how many dogs
baby dogs was gonna be born you know
yeah and people would be out there
betting yeah we had a lot of [ __ ] like
at the dentist you guessed how many
jelly beans were in the the mason jar
and you got like free dentistry it was
like that [ __ ] like that so yeah a lot
of times i like to drink with them
because somebody will like the most
common thing is like a lot of people
know the face but they might not know
the name it's like oh i've seen a video
of yours before but they don't know the
name so it's a lot of like oh are you
that guy are you that guy right and then
it kind of just like i think it's a cool
way to have like a narrative behind the
the tour name you know i think it's like
at first i was like i don't really care
it doesn't matter what the tour name is
um
but i think it is cool if you can have
kind of a overall theme of it so i talk
a little bit about in my standup about
being like just like you know people
they know the face but they don't know
the name what does that mean and people
rec people all the time think i'm trevor
lawrence jacksonville jaguars
quarterback i get tagged in his [ __ ]
yeah whenever they have a shitty game
people will dm me i've called you that
this week
you know saying to somebody trevor
lawrence yeah somebody called me trevor
noah before that's kind of cool because
that is nice that's progressive man that
is you got to get out there so you know
it's there's like three important
trevors in the world and i might be half
of one of them so
i think it's just a cool overall theme
you know of just being like you know
it's uh
the video stuff is great but you know
i've been doing stand-up for like nine
years now eight nine years so it's like
you know this this is it's like a
different lane it's different from
videos but it's just you know just good
good [ __ ] good time cool man
yeah congratulations yo we worked on a
show out in um
new jersey oh yeah [ __ ] uh remember
those two shows at night during covid
wasn't it yeah it was at a horse track
red bank new jersey red ocean
red bank yeah those were uh those were
interesting those were good shows it was
just so it was just such a weird setup
yeah it was a wild set up and the second
one was cold i remember really cold
really cool
yeah that was uh a year ago maybe that
was middle coveted that was pete covet
it was it was definitely over a year ago
because it was in it was
like october or november i remember i
was doing dates out there
um but we did do that man yeah that was
a
that was a good time but i just remember
that was the first time i really sat in
a crowd to watch a stand-up show it's
watch your set after because i feel like
as as a comedy you kind of just do your
[ __ ] you sit in the back
but when's the last time you just sat in
the middle of a crowd and just was like
i'm gonna just enjoy it for what it is
yeah it's much different you know it is
different well you start to see what
people are even some people you see also
they want to be there they start to know
the guy like i watched a show of brendan
chavs not long ago
and i was like oh a lot of these people
are happy just to see him because they
see him on video they see him on yeah
yeah you know
and it's like a lot of audience they
just want to come
it really is like a showing of support
like yeah like watching with a smile
almost right it's like yeah i think this
they might be like i think this guy's
funny they might think this guy is my
favorite comedian
but there's also this other separate
thing that it's just like i want to be
there with this person right you know
and it was also cool to give me more
assurance because after that show i was
talking to you and you're kind of like
yeah it was all right it was a little
like you felt a little like shaky on it
but i was sitting in the car i was like
you know everybody was laughing the
whole time so sometimes you know you
forget you're an outside this was
outside of super spaced out but every
table had their laughs yeah but you know
we you said you're like i was it was
okay i was like nah you were crushing
the whole time but it's weird it's weird
to think when you're up there that you
might not be doing well but then you you
put yourself in the crowd and you're
like oh it was great yeah so it was cool
to just be in the middle of it and kind
of just watch it and
it was fun man yeah
for some reason i always feel like i
didn't do good i think cause i just
whole i always want to do great yeah but
that means you care about the craft
every i mean like maybe like twice in my
life i've gotten off stage oh i [ __ ]
crushed it just sounds weird to get off
and be like i'm the man you know
so yeah sometimes i wish i had more of
that in me right i think it would do but
it's humbling well
yeah but there's definitely times you
get off you're like oh no that was a
good set but i would never like out loud
be like oh [ __ ] murdered that [ __ ] it
just sounds crazy because then somebody
else is like
all right it's seven minutes yeah but if
a
if a woman hears it they're like that
guy's a king
you know i'm gonna start saying it i'm
gonna say it this weekend yeah murder
that [ __ ] i don't know i just feel like
coming up in the open mic scene you
would hear somebody be like oh [ __ ]
crushed and then you like watch your set
and you're like
right astric maybe what does that mean
so you just kind of like
yeah i don't want to
i don't know maybe i think it's just an
artist thing to always think you could
do better because i feel the time all
the way every time i post a video i'm
like i could have done this could have
done that every time i get upset i'm
like could have done this something's
wrong in my head i wake up in the
morning and i'm thinking [ __ ] man you
could do better than that just second
you wake up every day that's it
ah it's a negative start brother
positive affirmations some people wake
up and they're like you can do this you
are all holy you are god and you just
look in the mirror man [ __ ]
brick
yeah [ __ ] st rock
strike on a tuesday right out of the
gate but it's good uh but sometimes some
days it's it it some days it gets better
um
what else was i gonna ask you about dude
uh oh i saw you at simon rex's movie
premiere yeah simon rex is uh one of
those guys who i've just like been
watching for forever yeah and it was
cool to kind of like get connected with
him but yeah we saw a red rocket and uh
there's a lot of big fan of you
someone's a big fan of yours simon
simon's great man yeah no he's the best
he's really good really talented actor
too yeah that was wild huh yeah how wild
has that whole i mean
simon wreck and
uh simon's been on here before him and
actually uh young gravy yeah that's a
boy of mine too yeah and
simon
um and simon's been in front of simon's
like the first guy that really kind of
turned me on in some ways onto people he
like i remember he put out a tweet one
day and he's like hey man this guy just
said some really nice [ __ ] and i was
like oh my god about you yeah yeah yeah
and then i saw him at one of my shows
and he was sitting just sitting in the
back and and i got to meet him i was
stoked and then we became
really close friends actually um
for a while the pandemics kind of kept
us separate butt yeah but he kind of
checked it was weird because he was just
fully off the grid and pandemic he moved
to like like the desert yeah and then
out there and then he got this call for
this he got this call for this movie red
rocket and then he's i think he won he
was winning [ __ ] for that he was on the
front page of the hollywood reporter
yeah so it's like sometimes that's just
the journey in the path not to get all
[ __ ] zenned out cbd uh but it is
there's no
i don't know if there's a better story
he's the uh
he's like almost uh dude he was banging
paris hilton at one point yeah i mean
yeah and there's if that yeah there's
definitely up from there yeah
but but it's just like you would never
be like i'm gonna go to the desert and
then book a movie role sometimes you
just gotta go and like give it time and
like figure out what you really want and
i mean he's proven himself to so many
industries
well he's just been
i mean just to have gone
and
ben like i'm just going to do what i
want to do build himself at home i'm out
in the desert i'm going to chill out
sean baker the director or whatever sees
him from instagram or from something or
just sees his work or sees who he is
yeah i think yeah and he said this is
the guy who can play this role and that
was the amazing thing about the role
it's like
i don't know if anybody else could have
been
that perfect for it right it just fit
him it didn't even look like he was
acting he was just being that character
right and that's what like the best
acting is people that don't look like
they're acting yeah that's pretty tough
man you [ __ ] you think about you for
me acting feels like i'm just high i'm
thinking about every move i'm like would
i say that is that right
here we go
and he crosses all right oh the guy
walks in how are you oh you're doing
good yeah just yeah acting is really do
you want to do does it make you want to
do it i know you had to show you i was
pitching some stuff i would only want to
do if it was with my friends and like uh
there wasn't high stakes if it was like
super high stakes where it's like you
know me and timothy you know chalamet
got a riff on some [ __ ] i'm like nervous
i'm in my head i'm like this jawline you
could [ __ ] cut a pepperoni with that
so like i'm just getting like i would
get my head i would want to like if
being you were like doing something or
like i was on like if i did dave or
something with with like little dickie
and santino like that would be cool
because you're like it feels like a
little less pressure but even then
there's [ __ ] 75 people on set there's
somebody who just brings you like a hair
tie and i don't even need the [ __ ] in my
hair right now like it's just too much
sometimes it's like i like how i film
where it's like me a few other people
and a camera guy like like three people
max three four people right because then
it's just like what's it it's in your
con
in your control
you know
so you get to be the editor of it so you
really get to be
do you think that's part of it i think i
think i like being in control i also i
feel like the more people the more
expectations the i think like i love and
stand up when i'm blinded like when it's
like the the light is super bright on me
because like when i can see everybody in
the crowd i get in my head and i'm like
oh [ __ ] this person's not looking at me
they're on their phone this and that so
i get in my head easily and then if i'm
looking behind a camera and then there's
like 40 people behind it sometimes it's
hard to zone out and be like okay just
do it your best at zone in on your craft
because sometimes you're thinking and
you see somebody like [ __ ] like roll
their eyes in the back you know like am
i bombing up here
right you see somebody drink out of a
cup or something you're like what what
the [ __ ] are you thirsty doing my [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] dry throat you're not
laughing dude lube up them chops so yeah
can't you see bro i'm [ __ ] making
magic yeah and and i've been on a few
sets before and it's just like a lot of
long days
it just takes the funny out of it the
best stuff is like is pointing at your
camera man big oh get this real quick
get this real quick but you can't go up
to a [ __ ] dp who gets paid 97 a
minute and be like yo get this he's like
what this ain't a vlog
so
i'm off the clock yeah well exactly he's
like you got to get that approved by
this and that i mean yeah the best part
about the sets is just they got a lot of
like licorice that's nice yeah they got
the snacks that thing is nice but i mean
think about it sometimes yeah i think
about like do what uh i sometimes it'd
be nice to have a break from uh
doing
uh touring and stuff but i guess you can
just take a break yeah um i would want
to work on something that i was a fan of
i think i would say if i you know i i
hadn't i've had auditions for like all
types [ __ ] but one i don't audition for
a curb and then when i was like legit
stoked on and then they rifle there
wasn't the the interview not the
interview [ __ ] up that's why i don't
book anything
audition you're just supposed to riffle
a scene and i was like that's
um that's that's dope that's amazing
you're not like trying to focus over
word by word you're just like this is my
interpretation of it that type of [ __ ]
i'm cool if i was a fan of the i be down
but sometimes they're like all right
you're gonna play a marshmallow and a
sci-fi like what the [ __ ] even is this
and that's a real audition i went on
last year yeah and i did not get it even
worse
when some of these things they sent me
out on damn i can't be a dessert it's
funny because i get these auditions and
i think like i don't want to do this
[ __ ] it's like well you can't even book
it dog right okay what do you have to
complain about you didn't even book
being somebody's ugg boot you [ __ ]
so i mean yeah that is a good point man
cause i'll say a lot of times like man i
would hate to do that [ __ ] but then i'm
not even getting offered to do that yeah
actually i've gotten offered some things
i got offered different voices and
sit and uh animations and stuff like
that that i've passed on yeah i think
sometimes just amount of time have you
done traditional stuff like you've been
on like enough sets and [ __ ] huh
i've done some stuff i got to uh almost
did a movie with chris pratt okay but
that was like um i got there and it was
just so much it was like a 12-week
commitment saying it's insane and it was
just such a small thing and it was just
who were you playing i'm grateful to him
i was just playing like uh
it was like kind of like a rednecky kind
of guy in a uh
postpartum war or something so you in
like 2073.
yeah something like that all right and
it was cool i saw i saw it it was cool
oh you saw the dude who played your role
no they didn't end up putting another
person that's good i think i would have
been pissed they put somebody else in
there but i think when i got there they
didn't exactly even know what the role
was they were still figuring it out that
was the interesting thing it was just
such a like leap of faith i think was
chris just like which is insane just
call him first name basis was he was he
just like oh i [ __ ] with theo let's just
get him in on something
yeah yeah that's cool he actually just
hit me up and asked me and um that's
that's how i think it should be more of
yeah you know i think it is everything's
getting like that yeah i think so you
know all the it's like you just hit your
friends up and say sometimes anyway we
think about like sam like he's just been
casting his homies for the past like 30
years and that's the way to do it that's
why the chemistry is so great and it's
like you see and people are like oh they
work so well on screens like it's their
20th movie together yeah but that was
another thing that was there there was
no that's one thing that spade always
says he's like dude if you're going to
do a movie you want to spend time with
your friends it's going to be six weeks
you know at least with who you want to
be with right you want to probably be
with buddies or people you enjoy having
dinner with
um
but
yeah i don't know i mean these days you
just don't know i know tim dillon wants
to do a movie you know people want to do
different things right
i think it would be interesting i think
to do something and then just sell it
directly to people yeah you know that's
what i think would be really interesting
yeah the hard part is like 97 platforms
to stream on now but it's like i can
shoot something and put a little bit of
money into it just put it on youtube or
something i i don't really know what i
don't know what people
want these days you know
yeah and you told me and i remember this
you know that people like a lot of uh
your crew they don't it's hard to even
watch a long movie bro my phone goes off
i get one text i can't go more in two
minutes without being all right who is
it bank of america or the homies right
neither but for watching a movie you
mean yeah it's just something about like
like i almost got to put my [ __ ] on
airplane mode just so i don't even think
about it because it's like if your phone
buzzes it's weird to not be like oh i
wonder what that is
right you you can go straight to start
to finish on the movie no phone touch
uh it's hard but it's definitely
happening more but like but i'm trying
to do it purposely but sometimes i'm
like you ever said your phone off for
like half a day
i need to
i i got a buddy who's all into that [ __ ]
he'll like turn his phone off and go to
the beach and i'm like i just all in it
would he be just being just he just
leaves it at home and this drives to the
beach but i'm like how the how do you
get to the beach you just head west
i don't know yeah that part is weird
because then you like i don't know
no it's not great i [ __ ] i watch tick
tock till my eyes are bleeding like it's
not good it's not good well i started
noticing when a lot of tick tock the
songs would show up in my dreams that i
was oh no
that's horrendous i know the renegades
on there while you're just on a dragon
oh i knew i wasn't doing good you know
yeah it's yeah it's honestly it's it's
muscle memory it's like i'll be paying
and then i'm just scrolling it's like if
i liked your instagram photo i was
probably paying my dick was in the other
hand i should be in jail for that
a lot of pedos out there man [ __ ] i
wouldn't put me in that boat but you
know uh well not you but i'm just saying
it's not
i don't know if it's more popular or
less popular
yeah um i think there's a lot of more
closeted ones because you can see so
much stuff there's a lot of like
i'm amazed there's not things that block
someone
um
an adult from talking to a child on
you'd think social media platform you'd
think it's just like how do they feel no
responsibility for that like that feels
crazy oh like google
or no like instagram or snapchat like
there's nothing that says
that a 40 year old can't talk to a 15
there's no like
thing that stops one from messaging the
other
that is weird you should have to answer
a question before you dm that person
you're like what's your favorite care
bear and if you answer that jail yeah if
you answer that even type out a letter
yeah anything that's just not no
yeah it is weird i don't know but the
web is like there's so many layers like
my friends were like showing me like how
deep you can get on reddit like what
type of weird [ __ ] you can find in there
and it's like that's evian oh yeah you
can there's like what is it what's all
on there i don't even i don't even know
it's like a forum and there's like
little sub reddits which is like a
smaller forms like groups of like
literally anything see some of that i
use reddit for porn i'm not gonna lie
but really yeah you can you can find
some cool stuff in there because it's
just really specific stuff you know
like a girl choking on like a pine cone
or something oh damn yeah yeah but oh
that's reforestation
right yeah that's the real forest gump
right there but uh
so
but yeah it's just like it's you can get
so deep down and just kind of anything
it's like the internet probably does try
to like block out the weirdos but
there's probably people jerking off of
the chick-fil-a website being honest
just finding something on there to get
off to oh do we stuff a guy i remember
they would come pick up a girl at our
school and i think he was i don't know
if he was a pedophile but he was just
older you know
it sounds like yeah and he would all
remember tell us about using like the
wendy's rapper the grease from the
wendy's rapper to play with his play
with his body yeah that man should be uh
castrated
and i still sometimes i wish i didn't
think about that but sometimes i still
think about it you ever drive by wendy's
and be like
i could try it
they do have pretty greasy burgers no i
don't think about it like that i just
think sad about i just think man i wish
that i didn't know that yeah i wish god
didn't let me know that you wish that
wendy didn't have the frosty so he can
disassociate the two
dude when i was in
like junior high
yeah that dude that came i remember that
would like do the bacon like the
hamburger
that guy wendy's guy yeah he drove like
this yellow
cutlass sedan kind of car
and um
he
had like
done he you know like people used to put
flames on the side of stuff to make it
look cool yeah but he'd taken like a
blowtorch and like just burnt the side
of his car and it was like let's make it
look like he was driving the speed of
light yeah it was just like
some of his like his his plan his like
like plans didn't translate i don't
think that good but um i mean if there's
ever a car to touch herself in that's up
there oh i might be three or four ah the
seats were so comfortable i think a
pontiac
aztec probably number one car you touch
yourself in aztec oh yes i mean it's
just a weird car but they don't catch
your eye enough but if you look close
they're probably dude rubble one out in
there
dude we have a lot of men would drive
over by the um win dixie in our town and
all
be back there crying or touching
themselves it's one of the other
some do you think they ever did both at
the same time can you be hard and crying
um i don't think i could honestly that
seems like a lot of stimulation at once
okay i think i i think i probably you
gotta focus i feel like the immediate
answer was yes in my head it's like as
sad as that you're happy tears maybe you
can do happy tears but you can't be like
bawling about like a dog passed away
that's weird yeah i don't think you'd be
balling about it um what else is it
gonna say oh uh oh we had a lot of narcs
back then because i remember a lot of
dudes would get sent back to our school
and they'd be narcs you know yeah and uh
we had a few of those the jrotc kids did
y'all yeah they they would like dress up
like cops on like friday nights at
football games and they just pretty much
just tell you to throw the trash away
yeah yeah i don't know what they're
doing now but and they would have wooden
guns sometimes and after school there
was always this group of kids running
around the halls with like wooden guns
yeah and there was jr it was like
flipping around and [ __ ] it was rotty
yeah yeah and they'd always be like have
like these kind of like semi
kind of like
marine haircuts yeah even though they
didn't have to get them i think they
just got them anyway you're gonna do it
and then they get themselves cauliflower
here a little bit just pause themselves
the wooden gun's weird because you're
like what are you gonna do to somebody
you must splinter in the forehead to
[ __ ] freeze
some of these dudes were savages and
they would all do that car speed thing
where they would race their cars and put
the quarter mile on the window you know
they would write it on there yeah yeah
that was huge like three points would
you tell a narc was it pretty obvious
they were just like when they weren't in
camo or whatever the [ __ ] they're
wearing cargo shorts in our town it was
easy to tell narcs because the police
were just it was small they're too nice
to him well and the guy would always
that we'd like what town are you from
and he would be like oh i'm from just
like right over it right over here right
over the creek
yeah anybody dog
towns around you know creeks around here
bro you just spilt an icelandic water
all right just pick a town bro you
couldn't even name a town and i remember
some of the narcs would be like this 35
oh they had like this one dude he was
like 35 years old and he came back as an
arc and he had real smooth skin and he
was like kind of uh
i don't know yeah that's big dark energy
if you've got smooth skin selling drugs
no zits and you're selling drugs that
doesn't check out and he would just yeah
he would like he kept saying uh that he
was from texas or something you know
some place that like people like knew
about but then it really had never been
and then i remember he started dating a
girl at our school
and then they busted him for being a
pervert
and he was supposed to be busting us
damn it be your own narcs you know you
married that girl lauren actually which
is crazy he went to jail i think and
then got out and then married her for
pedophilia
i mean i think he went for
a you know indecency with a minors i
think a lot of why was it always history
teachers that were the closest to
pedophiles our history teacher he would
knock girls pencils off the desk so he'd
check out the rack when he dropped it
now that's not to give anybody ideas but
he would like like if you were like oh
uh what what's what's the answer you
knock off the pencil so you'd like reach
down and he would just stare at the
grand tetons stare at them nugs
them young nuggets and he did that for a
couple of years real thick glasses
17 year old tits would you look at them
[Laughter]
i'm not looking
because it seems like
you're looking bro it seems like you're
an ark right now dude
where's his feet going huh where's his
feet going nashville pd
is just a straight is that a producer is
he a narc
yeah i mean that's a crazy question
is it that crazy
yeah but this guy dude he came back to
our school yeah and he's like his first
thing was like who's he who's selling
drugs and we're like what that's what
i'm saying the questions they ask are
crazy who's trying to do the weed the
the
who wants to smoke meth out of a spork
dog gets a spoon [ __ ] act right
dude narcs are always the dude
and it was always some kid usually that
had been in school for so long and
couldn't graduate school he dropped out
and now so like he's fake dropped out
but he still went to class under like an
alias you know what you're back with
like a different name yeah yeah you're
like this dude couldn't spell his first
name yeah his original name is he's
lance and narcs never had plans what are
you guys doing tonight it's like you
just know what you're doing on a friday
in high school you know but if you have
to ask for plans narc narcs never had
plans they got like a face tattoo that's
just a henna teardrop and you're like is
that is that a henna he's like yeah i
got this [ __ ] blasted last night dog you
remember the first time you saw a tit
out in public i remember mine
in public in new orleans you saw them
all the time that was the thing you had
mardi gras so that was another thing you
had like
you know high school chicks was always
out there showing their tits adult when
you'd have a you know you'd have a 17
year old and a 60 year old showing their
tits out there you know yeah i remember
i was at magic mountain and uh they had
this like uh or not imagine mountain
splash mount or what's the [ __ ]
raging waters one in california well
raging waters yeah it's the name of it
it's just like a amusement park but it's
all water
right see world sea world water park i
believe they call it these days water
park uh yeah not sea world no but it was
raging waters i don't know man i don't
know yeah but uh they had this
there was like this overflow of this
like water that waterfall yeah that was
like waterfall but like it was it wasn't
on purpose it was like overflow of a
ride because it was like a berm that
like spun out and it landed on this this
like mom and it hit the left side of her
bikini
and yeah there was tit out for like
seven seconds
she didn't even know it was
it was crazy i was like slapping my
friends bring them back bring them out i
was like hitting people i was like
[ __ ] uh unadulterated
in the wild god there's something about
it just just straight up pure tit
there's something about it stumble
across it and here's like a gold rush
but all over again yeah
there's nothing wrong with it man
there's nothing wrong with some of age
breasts of age breasts you know and she
was probably you know low 40s
inappropriate breasts you know when
breast is appropriate yeah there's a
time and a place oh
and it's often brother i will say that
thank god brother and that's okay that's
what god wanted
um are you that guy tour
trevor wallace you guys go check him out
man yeah man it's gonna be a good time
i'm really excited so
yeah thanks for getting me out of
hibernation dude i appreciate it yeah
man hopefully you had a good time and i
really didn't know you're taking this
time off i feel bad man but now we're
talking about tits and you're getting up
a lot around town out here or is that
where you're going back to lh you had a
function no just been taking a break
from everything right now so i'm gonna
go back to la and get more sets there
you go so that's one thing too that's uh
that's tougher outside of like there's
just nowhere to perform you know there's
one club yeah often you pop in there
sometimes yeah not a ton but even then
you do 10 minutes and you're like all
right now what yeah but i've also been
overall just been kind of just taking a
break yeah it's been kind of nice just
to like yeah i mean you have to yeah
when you get too intense you just burn
out you you're like just trying to make
material out of anything and you're like
carpet's crazy huh what the [ __ ] wrong
with me yeah now the more you like live
the more you live a life to tell about
it i think that's something i feel like
you know if you if you're not living i
remember i was really so i think said
that who didn't robinson caruso i think
said that
okay
i saw it on the back of a kid rock
t-shirt but do you really know oh but uh
i i just remember when i was first
moving to la all i did was open mics i'd
go to work and then i'd do like three or
four open mics tonight and then i just
try to just just give but i like i
wasn't talking about anything right i
was just trying to be funny but it
wasn't anything personal and then you
take some time to realize who you are as
a person and what made you you and your
background and this and that
and uh that's when you find the funny
yeah and then and then you find your
lane and you're like this is what i want
to talk about yeah i think i felt burn
out for a while i think i just got so
busy working naturally you know i took
on i was doing three episodes of i was
just doing way too much doing sets
touring you know it's just like you just
want to say yes to everything because in
the beginning you didn't have that right
when you
never had nothing yeah and you work so
hard and then something comes along man
you oh [ __ ] i hold on to something
yeah man but now i'm kind of realizing
like hey man i can have a little bit of
choice in
what i want to do because i just want to
feel like myself i don't want to be so
busy or overwhelmed that i don't feel
like myself right that's where i've been
i think it's a scary feeling oh you're
like it's just exhausting you're just
looking at what the stuff you're putting
out there you're like do i even like
this am i doing this joke for me or is
this just because i think it's funny
yeah this video just because i think
it's going to go viral but i don't
actually give a [ __ ] about it yeah do
you feel pressured to sometimes
create stuff yeah a lot of times it's
when i'm like in between touring a lot
and it's like there's like i have like
two days in town and i'm like okay i
need to make something let me uh what's
funny what uh okay this and then it's
like did i actually want to make that or
did i just rush it to put something out
and it shows when when the numbers come
up and it doesn't hit i go uh yeah that
makes sense that checks out but in the
beginning i just get pissed i'm like no
[ __ ] that's funny why didn't that hit
but now it's like i get i go i rushed
that
didn't need to do that should have just
taken that week off yeah and rested a
little bit but it takes time to learn to
do i'm overdue for a lot of
excuse me i'm overdue for a lot of weeks
off yeah but but i think the people who
support you the most would understand be
we would rather have theo at 100 than
being like here's a podcast but i
[ __ ] you know i have narcolepsy at
minute 36. yeah
yeah i just yeah i i want to i want to
get back to a place where i feel really
healthy you know and uh natural so in
january is weird because december's
really slow but then it's hard to go
straight back to 100
right i jumped right into it yeah
[ __ ] we're back you know this weekend
we're back right but yeah i'm trying to
just do a little bit less and just yeah
i'm all good though everything feels
good man i just wanna yeah i wanna i
wanna i realize that i can take more
time for myself because i wanna make
good stuff i wanna feel like myself so
um
yeah but man i'm grateful to spend time
with you dude yeah thank you i love you
one of the funniest guys dude your
videos always make me laugh
um i've even called you trevor lawrence
before to people dude and i hope you
don't stop and i thought your name was
travis when i first read it don't even
have you saved in my phone still this
travis
travis lawrence and that sounds like a
youth pastor
and tonight at zany's comedy club maybe
he will be now i'm just floating on the
breeze and i feel i'm falling like these
leaves i must be
cornerstone
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna
take a little time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
mine
[Music]
now